こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです！
かつて僕はこの部屋で
ブランコを作ろうと頑張った。
バンカーリングで。
その結果が！こちらだ♪
３！
２！
１！
あの、重すぎて失敗したんですけども....今回はそれのリベンジというか
もっとちょっと出来そうなのがあったので！それで、もう一度！室内で、ブランコをしてみようと思います！
こちら、マジックフックというものでございます。
あのよくあるフックなんですけども、
これが何かAmazonで見たら凄い強いみたいなことを情報手に入れました。
あ！これです！これです！
いや...もう凄いんすよ！
もう画像が全てを物語っているんですけども、人がぶら下がれるみたいです！
いやぁ凄い凄い！男の人が抜こうとしてもなんか抜けないみたいな
マジ凄いっす！てか実際何キロくらいまで耐えれるんだろう？
えっと、５㎏から10㎏まで耐えれるみたいです。
ちょっと足りんな。
1個だいたい10㎏。４つ使えば...40㎏...いや大丈夫っすよ
ちょっと不安になってきたな.....いやでも！！！！見てください！この女性がフック一つで浮いてるんで！
一つで女性が浮くんで きっと僕も大丈夫だと思います！！というわけで作っていきましょう！まずはブランコを作ります。
ブランコの板としてちょっとこれを使います。
このサイズ....ちょっとでかいな....ブランコの表面が大きいという事で
体の体重が分散するので、よりフック１つ当たりにかかる
重量がちょっと軽くなるというか均等になるんじゃないかと思ってこれを採用します。
まずは穴を開けていきます。
よし。いてっ！
よっしゃ
オッケー！穴が出来ました。ここに紐を通していきます。
オッケー、来た来た来た！
よし
これでブランコの１ヶ所が完成です！....ほっ....来た！オッケー！
完璧すぎて、ふるえる
ラスト！オッケー。あとはここを結んで...よし！はい！
紐はつけ終わりました！よし完璧です
ちゃんと４か所に紐がつきました。
じゃあ続いてはこのマジックフックを
部屋の四か所に
きれいな正方形を同じ長さになるように設置していきます
多分なんか
平べったい場所がいいって書いてあったので
ドアの方がいいかな
ドアにつけていきます！！
え！こんなのでほんとに10kgも耐えれるの？
え、なんかすごい心配なレベルなんですけど
頭のてっぺんぐらいの場所に置いていきます
はります
うわぁ　でも
強いな　これ多分
あ、強いわコレ！
あーこれなかなか
なかなか強いッス
結構いける説が浮上しております。これ。
あるぞ
うお～～　強い！！
はい！ よし！
さあ、続いては！
ブランコの紐をフックにかけていきます
ううー　心配　大丈夫かな？
はい
あっ　全然いけそう
全然、全然いけそう、、！
これで両サイドをこうすれば
おっおっおっおっおっおっおっ
できたできたできた！！
できました～～！！！！！
ぱちぱちぱち！
すごい！！すごい！！すごい！！
めっちゃバウンドする、、、
ちょっと板の柔らかさが気になるところではあるんですけども、、、
はい！！というわけで
いかがでしょうか
10kg
フック一つで女の人を一人
持ち上げられるんで
あとクッション性があるんで怖いんですけども
ついに！！！
家の中でブランコをできる日がやってきました
、、、怖いなぁ
大丈夫かなぁ？
ブランコというのは
もはや　空中ベットの勢いなんですけども
うわぁ　すごい、、、
ほんとに　すごいすごい！！
これマジでいけるぞ、多分
完全にブランコです
では　のってみます、、、！！
ズドンッッ！！！！！
下手クソな字幕を修正してみましたが、途中で命つきてしまいました。あとは、頼むっ。